and the rules of Islam it isn't about
punishment it isn't about harshness it's
just simply your instruction manual you
buy a car it comes with a manual what to
do what not to do so you don't wreck it
same way Allah created us he gave us a
manual for how we can have that peace
that Tranquility that success and that
happiness and there's a reason for our
choosing to leave the Deviant Lifestyles
by choice because they realize a life of
drinking of alcohol or drugs of open
relationships it doesn't bring that
peace of mind that the honor and the
guidance and the modesty and dignity
that Islam brings to humanity gives them
and that's why they're choosing it
that's what we're grateful to be Muslim
and that's why we invite everybody
watching to say get to know more about
Islam if you're Muslim appreciate it
don't take it for granted invest and
learn in your faith and if you're not
Muslim yet we're waiting for you
remember we all have one Creator and he
said Abraham Moses Jesus and Muhammad as
the best Role Models peace be upon them
all to guide us to him